michael k williams has died he was 54.
the game is out there and it's either
play or be a play the wire actor was
reportedly found dead in his brooklyn
penthouse monday afternoon he is
survived by his mother michael's famous
friends took to social media to share
their condolences
taraji p henson wrote rest well my
friend jesus you will be missed deeply
chance the rapper shared thanks for all
you gave to encourage enlighten and
entertain people you didn't even know
praying for your people and his the wire
co-star wendell pierce posted an
emotional tribute on twitter writing
always truthful never inauthentic the
kindest of persons like two mischievous
kids we would laugh and joke whenever we
would meet michael is best known for his
breakout role as omar little in the
gritty tv series it put us on the map it
did what it was supposed to do you know
and i'm grateful to still have a career
that people are still interested in and
to have the wire be my first baby
i mean right sky's the limit the 54 year
old actor also starred in several other
hit hbo series like boardwalk empire i
supply the product you and your people
work your magic
that's a whole lot of magic for only 20
percent and most recently lovecraft
country he was nominated for an emmy for
his role in the horror drama
you know what i what i mostly hope is
that uh
youth um particularly youth in my
community will
watch this and and get a sense of the
legacy
in which we come from um the greatness
and and
all the obstacles
that we've overcome to to to be alive
today and love our country in my opinion
gives us a blueprint
to how things got so divided to where we
are today
hopefully we can you know go back and
fix some things and start to fix our
things to make it a better future in
june michael gave a theatrical tribute
to the late dmx at the bet awards the
actor who bore an uncanny resemblance to
the rapper delivered a passionate
monologue in memory of his friend damn i
said i'm slipping i'm falling i got to
get up get back on my feet so i could
head on and in et's final interview with
michael he reflected on his friendship
with a rap superstar who died in april
from a drug-induced heart attack tell me
about i saw the picture that you posted
of unx and you guys were out what tell
me about that and your your relationship
with him and what he meant to you well
that night was random that was my son's
birthday and we i took him to gold bar
and x happened to be spinning that night
and um
that was the second time that i'd
actually met him i went to the dj booth
and we spoke about some uh
some personal things you know i've
always thought the kindred uh spirit to
that brother and um we talked about that
he looked at me hugged me and there you
go the picture was taken it'll be
special tonight it was a very special
night
[Music]
you